the Amazon rainforest stretches for
millions of kilometers
hiding ancient tribes animals and maybe
something else
what if under this mysterious canopy
lies an advanced civilization
how could we miss something so huge
is the rainforest just an overgrown
Garden
and why didn't these people fight off
the European Conquest
this is what if and here's what would
happen if an advanced civilization lived
in the Amazon
in the 1500s Spanish explorer Francisco
de Oriana returned from the Amazon with
wild Tales of a golden city called El
Dorado and warrior women in the jungle
but when others searched for Treasure
and Glory they all came back with
nothing
so what the heck
did they orianna make it all up
well for the next few centuries that's
what we thought but now thanks to
technology it looks like this Explorer
wasn't lying
using sophisticated aerial sensors
researchers created a 3D image of the
ground under the rainforest revealing a
hidden ancient city
that flies in the face of everything we
thought we knew about the Amazon but
what if these people still lived Among
Us
the Amazon is the size of India and much
of it lies beyond our reach
without this technology we might never
have seen What Lies Beneath the ground
so what else did we learn
humans flourished in the Amazon basin
for almost 10 000 years and they weren't
living in tiny mud Huts like you may
have seen in movies
these sprawling cities could have held
nearly 1 million people in their Prime
and if these complex sophisticated
people lived today the history of the
world would be radically different
the Amazon belonged to the kasarabi
people
and they didn't just adapt to the Jungle
they might have created it
well that's the theory anyway
researchers think that this Society
built Garden cities around the plant
life they selected
throughout the area the Brazil nut tree
dominates the land
is that a coincidence or is this how the
kasarabi fed their people
still not convinced
well the soil found in the Amazon
contains nutrients not found anywhere
else on Earth called Terra Preta this
dirt contains microbes that fertilize
Barren land but while we think humans
created this we still don't know exactly
how
okay well so what do we know
those images showed us they built
villages in geometric patterns
they clustered small communities around
larger ones
roads connected these settlements and
they even constructed waterways
waterways that could have controlled
seasonal floodings to grow crops and
farm fish
these intricate Amazon cities are older
than anything the ancient Greeks built
but what else did researchers find
well for one it looks like these Lost
Cities aligned with the Stars
this means these Builders had Advanced
knowledge of astronomy
the kasarabi built a civilization that
rivaled anything on Earth at the time
so what happened to them
well we still don't know but remember
these people depended on flood waters
for almost everything if water became
scarce during a drought much of their
civilization could have died out
and whatever happened
they were gone for 100 years before the
Spanish arrived
just enough time for the jungle to
reclaim their once Great Society
but if the kasarabi survived they could
have grown even more advanced
learning more about math science and
astronomy
they might have even fought off the
European conquest of South America
masters of the land these experienced
jungle Warriors could have created
alliances with other cultures like the
Aztecs or Incas
this Army might have changed the face of
history as we know it and if the
Invaders and the kasarabi called a truce
maybe the two societies could have
traded knowledge
the people of the Amazon could have
integrated European Transportation
methods and weaponry into their everyday
lives
while diseases like smallpox would still
have been devastating they might have
developed medicines or immunity to fight
it off
more importantly all the minerals and
precious materials hidden in South
America would have remained in South
America
and Spanish wouldn't be the third most
spoken language on the planet because
these citizens would proudly speak in
their native tongue
the Nations we know now could be
completely different United under an
Amazonia culture but hey that could
still happen now
like what if South America became one
country
well stick around because that's a story
for another what if
[Music]